do you believe what you said that putin
can't remain in power or do you now
regret saying that because your
government has been trying to walk that
back did your words complicate matters
well you asked three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back the fact of the
matter is i was expressing the more
outrage i felt toward the way putin is
dealing and the actions of this man
just just
brutality
half the children in ukraine i just come
from
being with those families
and uh and so i but i want to make it
clear i wasn't then nor am i now
articulating the policy change i was
expressing the moral outrage that i feel
and i make no apologies for you personal
feelings sir your personal feelings my
personal feelings
secondly you asked me about uh
well what was the second does it
complicate the diplomacy of this moment
no i don't think it does you know
the uh
the fact is that we're in a situation
where uh
um
what complicates the situation at the
moment is the
uh the escalatory
efforts of putin
to uh continue and engage in carnage the
kind of behavior that
that makes the whole world say my god
what is this man doing
that's what complicates things a great
deal and uh
but i i don't think it complicates at
all
let me go to steve hall reuters
mr president thank you when you say that
you're not walking anything back you do
feel that vladimir putin should be
remained from removed from power is that
what you're saying no what i was i was
expressing just what i said i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
towards this man i wasn't articulating a
policy change
and
i think that
you know he continues on this course
that he's on
he is going to become a pariah worldwide
and who knows what he'd come becomes at
home in terms of support just to follow
up are you concerned this remark might
escalate the conflict
no i'm not
i'm not at all
look thank you
and you know look the the other thing is
that uh
a couple people have asked me as well
might well speak to unless you want to
ask the question but uh
you know uh that other government
suggested that this is a problem i'm
escalating things
uh no
and as a weakened nato
no it hadn't
nato has never ever ever ever ever ever
been as strong as it is today
never
so if saying he cannot remain in power
does not mean regime change what does it
mean
it means that i would hope
i just it was expressing my outrage he
shouldn't remain in power just like you
know bad people shouldn't continue to do
bad things but it doesn't mean we have a
fundamental policy to do anything to
take putin down in any way what made you
add that because that wasn't in your
prepared remarks we were told so what
made you add that at the end mr
president because i was talking about i
was talking to them to the russian
people the last part of the speech was
talking to the russian people telling
what we thought
i was communicating this to not only the
russian people but the whole world
this is this is just stating a simple
fact
that
this kind of behavior
is totally unacceptable
totally unacceptable and the way to deal
with it is to strengthen and
put
keep nato completely
united and help ukraine where we can